hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the import one of
his Nicomachean ethics Aristotle is
going to make a set of very important
remarks primarily as you can see over
here in chapters two in Chapter seven of
the work they have to do with what we
can call principles or our case starting
points for a moral inquiry for the field
of ethics and the issue of exactness or
precision the Greek word for those extra
days how precise can we be in carrying
out our reasonings and in drawing our
conclusions is that like something like
some people have called it at you know
it was a popular thing to talk about it
as being a science the science of morays
or the science of duties isn't a science
in the way that say mathematics is a
science
it was the same level of exactness or
precision or is it somewhat of a looser
type of inquiry does it have any reader
if it doesn't have that sort of examples
these are very important questions and
this issue of principle and this issue
of exactness can they fit in together
they inform each other
as we're going to
so where we need to start is in
Aristotle's dictum that you're going to
see both in the mecha mechanics and also
in other works like for example the
topics where he says that we should aim
for the measure of exactness or
precision now of one science or
discipline being the paradigm for
everything but rather in terms of the
subject matter whatever it is that that
discipline happens to deal with the the
the precision that's demanded is what
the subject matter itself can only pair
can allow what it can admit what it
permits and he'll go on to be senses
it's the mark of an educated mind
actually to not expect more precision
than as possible so you know if you
think about this it's possible to be
that precise enough to be too vague to
be too general to not get down to the
level of exactness that we would like
that of those subject matter admits of
and then when we're talking about
mathematics which is his paradigm here
for something which is very exact you
know that's quite a low level you know
we can get really down to the most basic
level in part because numbers are
totally commensurable with each other
and you know one one or two is pretty
much the same as as any other one isn't
it so it's easier to be very very exact
in things that are mathematize small
things that are quantitative when we get
to the realm of quality and when we get
to the realm of human agency which is
what ethics is dealing with we're
talking about something that isn't quite
so exact in that sense but it's not that
it's exact exactness is due to something
being wrong with the discipline itself
it's rather than we're dealing with
human
chairs that are always as Aristotle is
going to say you know epitope Allu
meaning for the most part not always not
universally so with a generality rather
than universality that is endemic to
Netflix and the educated person is not
going to expect that we can actually
provide prescriptive guidelines down to
the very level of action itself we can
provide as I put here general outlines
is what we'll talk about in a moment so
what can we say about the subject matter
of ethics he talks about this in Chapter
two but also in other places in chapter
two he tells us that it has to do with
these these two moral values in
particular one is what we translate as
the noble Tokai long right and we can
translate that not only as the noble but
is the honorable then which has
intrinsic goodness the beautiful to find
its opposite is the ignoble or the base
the ugly the foul the shameful the
dishonorable so that success to do with
that in part it also has to do with
justice to a decal or DTM and that
comprises a whole range of things as
well you can check out the other many
videos that we have in this series that
deal with different senses of justice as
Aristotle talks about so ethics is a
pretty broad purview doesn't it it deals
with human affairs and it's not just
about those things it's also about
pleasure and pain it's also about
evaluating different kinds of lives
against each other it's about actions
it's about emotions it's about choices
and it's about habits you see we're
dealing with a very wide range of human
phenomena here and all of them are
pretty murky and messy so it's it's
unrealistic to expect us to
with hard and fast rules that apply in
every single case and you know think
that we can have a something lighting
science and in that respect does that
mean that it's all totally arbitrary it
can't you know have any sort of progress
in understanding these maps aerosol says
look what we can do is provide outlines
the word that he uses there is literally
to sort of like provide the the
boundaries within which then we're going
to color adult coloring books are
becoming pretty popular I think in part
because human beings like to do that
sort of behavior but Aristotle thinks
that this is what we can do in terms of
that we can provide guidelines and a
fairly high level of generality
understanding that there will be
exceptions to them but that they are
holding for the most part most people
little like I said in Greek and so we
can provide outlines and we can also
engage in moral reasoning and come up
with general conclusions now when we get
down to individual cases that doesn't
mean that we can't actually provide
specific conclusions with some degree of
exactness however that's always going to
require that we understand and we have a
good judgment have a good sense of what
is going on at the particular level so
what we generalize about at the higher
level may not actually work out
automatically at the particular level
which is where things really happen
individual action takes place individual
lives relationships there's a very
important interplay there and again
we're going to shoot other videos about
what the things that go into that we
just want to get this general notion
about the level of exactness that's
possible now Arizona says that these
elements can be filled in and completed
if the outlines themselves are in the
right kind of outlines if they've been
adequately worked out then they can be
filled in
and complete it by just about any person
so long as they aren't you know morally
damaged or vicious or off
he also says interestingly enough that
time itself so you thinking about kind
of Primus in in moral inquiry time
itself helps us to fill in some of these
outlines and so from generation to
generation or perhaps from culture to
culture we may in fact arrive at a
better starting point in ethics then
previous people started out with now
this is a good point to talk about
principles or starting points for moral
inquiry moral reasoning thinking things
out and working out it has to happen in
specific cases deciding pray over these
all the sorts of things that go into
ethics so we always have to use some
starting points we don't reason in a
vacuum and we don't just simply look at
sensible particulars and immediately
start out from them we always have some
basic ideas or rules or conceptions that
we are using to make sense of things so
where do we get those from Aristotle
says in the Nicomachean ethics that we
get these from various means we acquire
them in different ways I only put two on
the board that are particularly
interesting and the third one that he
talks about is what is called perception
by stasis which doesn't mean just like
looking at things or smelling them or
hearing them although it does cover that
Aristotle thinks that we actually can't
i stasis were perception of things like
the noble and the the just he talks
about that at multiple points he also
thinks that we have perception sort of
general features of situations that
we're in so it's not just sense
perception but you might say grasping
what has been called the ethical
salience it's a beautiful term used by
Nancy Sherman in discussing this
now what we want to talk about here is
not perception so much rather induction
Epico game which means that a process of
you know sort of generalizing from what
we observe it's not the same thing as
experience but it goes a little bit
beyond mere experience and then really
important for ethics habituation for
Aristotle the principles that we need in
order to engage in fully well-informed
moral reasoning have to be eventually
available to us through the bitumen so
they're not principles in the sense of a
proposition that you write on the board
they're more something like a starting
point that has been embodied in the
fabric of your character the fabric of
your personality so that you begin from
the right points Aristotle thinks that
this is this is possible and in fact is
highly desirable because lacking that
it's going to be much harder to grasp
some of the things that he is laying out
in outline so some of those outlines
will require being filled in by somebody
who's had the right kind of habituation
there's a lot of other issues that we
could talk about here well what do you
do if you don't have the proper
habituation you know a lot of the time
when we come to this we realized wow I'm
kind of messed up and I'd like to get
less messed up there's little sense
you've got some things to work with but
the goal is actually to increase the the
number and the needs you might say
capacity of the principles that you're
working with so he really stresses the
the importance of what he calls proper
upbringing he says that you know you
need to have some experience of life and
you want to have a wide range of
experience but experience is not enough
you need to have been brought up with
some of the rights habits of mind and
of action and emotion or you'll have to
develop that over time he also stresses
something else that's very interesting
as well
maturity he thinks is needed in order to
successfully work in in ethics in order
to think through issues in order to to
make sense of things and he says that
the younger not really suitable students
for Ethics ironic since that's when we
tend to teach them this sort of stuff
and we don't do it when they're older in
part because they don't have enough life
experience but also in part because they
tend to be led by passion instead of by
reason by emotion sort of reason he also
says though that this can apply to older
people it can be the case that older
people lack sufficient experience and
maybe that they've done a lot of stuff
but they didn't pay attention so then
that would mean those principles are not
really available to them it can also be
the case that those people have the
principles but are not really able to
work with them or act upon them in part
because they don't follow reason or
those principles instead they just
follow their emotions and when they do
that that typically becomes a matter of
habits habits that are very difficult to
break once you become an adult and start
to consolidate them so maturity is not
merely an issue of age you know number
of years it can also be a matter of
one's attitude towards things ones one's
habitual way of doing things all of this
is important to bring back to this
notion of exactness ethics is going to
require of us then we have developed
certain capacities to grasp principles
that are not quite so easy and evident
to grasp as say those of mathematics the
Aristotle will say in a different point
this is why the young are great at doing
mathematics not so great at doing moral
reasoning but he might say that about
other people as well so to go back to
this ethics does have a certain level of
exactness in order for it to really have
the kind of exactness that most people
want of it it requires some personal
development so that you can actually
apply these things well when we get down
to the level no longer just general
conclusions or principles but the
particulars among which we actually live
act and choose